me acaban de mandar este problema y es
un problema bien padre mucho más jugoso
de lo que se puede encontrar en los
libros así que pensé que nos ayudaría a
ti ya mí resolverlo es esos problemas
que cuando lo ves de lejos hasta te
duelen los ojos pero una vez que
entiendes que pregunta es bastante
interesante dice la curva en la
siguiente figura es la parábola igual a
equis cuadrada entonces esta curva es
igual a equis cuadrada diremos que una
recta es normal si es una recta cuya
intersección con la parábola en el
primer cuadrante es perpendicular a la
parábola ok el de arriba a la derecha es
el primer cuadrante entonces le pongo
aquí uno y nos están diciendo que una
recta normal es una recta cuya
intersección con la parábola es
perpendicular es decir si dibujamos aquí
la tangente entonces la recta normal
debe de ser perpendicular a esa tangente
es todo lo que nos están diciendo esta
es una recta normal le escribo por aquí
normal ahora en la figura se muestran
cinco rectas normales 1 2 3 4 y 5 muy
bien y cada una de ellas si se ve
perpendicular a la parábola en el primer
cuadrante hasta ahorita nada raro por un
rato
la coordenada de x de la intersección en
el segundo cuadrante de una recta normal
con la parábola se hace más pequeña
conforme la coordenada en x en el primer
cuadrante se hace pequeña uff esta es
una frase sota vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando se va haciendo más pequeña la
coordenada en x en el primer cuadrante
vamos a la figura a ver si comienzo en
este punto de por aquí la coordenada en
x pues proyectando queda más o menos por
aquí y conforme nos vamos moviendo hacia
la izquierda digamos a este punto de acá
que le sucedió a la recta normal o bueno
más bien que le sucedió a la
intersección de la recta normal en el
segundo cuadrante estoy acá es el
segundo cuadrante entonces para cuando
tenía un valor mayor la recta normal
interceptaba por acá en el segundo
cuadrante pero luego cuando hacer que x
a cero es decir cuando hice más pequeño
el valor de x el segundo punto de
intersección de por acá que venía de la
normal en este punto se recorrió a la
derecha pero aquí hay algo raro verdad
porque en la oración nos dicen que la
coordenada de x se hace más pequeña y no
es realmente como que se esté haciendo
más pequeña sino que se está haciendo
menos negativa
pero bueno creo que en la oración con
más pequeñas se refieren a que va a ser
más cercana a 0 o sea que es más pequeña
en valor absoluto la coordenada se va
pegando a 0 y eso como un número quiere
decir que se hace más grande pero bueno
en la oración se refieren a que cuando
vamos moviendo hacia la izquierda el
valor de x las coordenadas en x de las
intersecciones de las rectas en el
segundo cuadrante pues también se van
pegando hacia el eje es decir se mueven
hacia la derecha va sigamos pero
eventualmente la intersección en el
segundo cuadrante de una recta normal se
hace lo más pequeña posible entonces en
el dibujo vamos a seguir recorriendo
hacia la izquierda hasta llegar a este
punto de por acá la recta normal por
este punto interfecta en el segundo
cuadrante por aquí y luego si nos
pasamos de ese punto las rectas normales
comienzan a interceptar en el segundo
cuadrante más y más a la izquierda
entonces podemos pensar a la
intersección de la recta extrema con la
parábola como el punto que alcanza la
coordenada en x más grande o dicho de
otra forma la coordenada en valor
absoluto más pequeña lo voy a volver a
decir
mira acá la derecha cuando teníamos
valores muy grandes de x las
intersecciones de las rectas normales
también tenían x es muy grandes
negativas pero conforme nos movemos a
este punto la equis de la intersección
es menos negativa podemos seguir hasta
este punto de acá este punto hace una
recta normal cuya intersección tiene el
valor de x más grande posible pero a
partir de allí si acercamos el punto más
a cero entonces las rectas se empiezan a
alejar en el segundo cuadrante yo creo
que eso es a lo que se refieren ahora
esta recta normal extrema se muestra con
mayor grosor en la figura sí sí en
efecto verdad aquí está marcada es más
vamos a indicar la todavía más para
acordarnos la voy a señalar y le voy a
poner extrema después de este punto
conforme nos acercamos más a cero las
intersecciones en el segundo cuadrante
se empiezan a alejar si quieres entender
un poco más qué está pasando con el
problema pues acércate todavía más a
cero eso nos acerca el caso extremo
donde la recta es perpendicular al eje x
y por tanto la intersección queda bien
bien alejada pero bueno vamos a acabar
de leer el resto del problema una vez
que las rectas normales pasan la recta
extrema las coordenadas de x de la
intersección con la parábola en el
segundo cuadrante comienzan a aumentar
otra vez verdad cuando dicen aumentar en
realidad se están refiriendo a que son
más negativas a lo mejor aquí debería de
aclarar más negativas o sea son números
que se hacen más grandes negativamente
otra vez cuando pasamos el punto las
coordenadas se empiezan a alejar del eje
y sale vale la figura muestra dos pares
de rectas normales si en efecto y ambas
rectas de cada par tienen la misma
intersección con la parábola en el
segundo cuadrante pero una está sobre la
recta extrema en el primer cuadrante y
la otra está por debajo si por ejemplo
la recta normal por este punto de por
acá intercepta en el segundo cuadrante
en este punto y luego si disminuimos y
disminuimos el valor de x hasta pasar la
recta normal llegamos a este punto que
que no más bien a este punto cuya recta
normal interfecta también en el mismo
punto a la parábola en el segundo
cuadrante bien
espero estar aclarando t el problema
mientras yo también me lo aclaró a mí
mismo ahora sí vamos a las preguntas yo
creo que solo nos va a dar tiempo de
hacer el inciso a el otro lo dejamos
para otro vídeo dice encuentra la
ecuación de la recta normal extrema uff
qué impactante se ve dificilísimo pero
bueno no hay que preocuparnos nuestra
caja de herramientas de derivación es
súper amplia y seguro con alguna de esas
va a salir manos a la obra comenzamos
cuando encontrar la pendiente en cada
punto a la gráfica para esto tenemos que
tomar la derivada de igual a x al
cuadrado simplemente que prima es igual
a 2x esto de aquí es la pendiente de la
tangente en cualquier punto x en x
entonces si quisiera saber la pendiente
en x0 en algún x particular simplemente
diría lo voy a poner por aquí entonces
nos quedaría 2x 0 es decir efe x 0 es
igual a 2 veces x 0 esto va a ser la
pendiente de la tangente en cualquier
punto particular x 0 entonces pues a ver
la pendiente de la recta normal es
perpendicular está pendiente ahora esto
ya lo vimos en otros vídeos para esto
hay que cambiar el signo y voltearlo es
decir la recta normal tiene pendiente la
pendiente de la recta normal en x0 va a
ser cambiarle el signo y ponerlo en
denominador entonces sería igual a menos
1 entre 2 x 0 va ahora cuál es la
ecuación de la recta normal por el punto
x0 vamos a suponer que este de aquí es
x0 y cuál va a ser la ecuación de la
recta normal a y bueno pues simplemente
podemos utilizar la fórmula de punto
pendiente
entonces este punto de aquí va a estar
en la recta normal y es x 0 x 0 al
cuadrado porque también sabemos que está
en la parábola verdad en la parábola de
igual a x al cuadrado entonces esta
recta normal también va a tener el punto
x 0 x 0 al cuadrado de esta forma la
ecuación de la recta normal
recta normal va a ser igual a voy a
poner la forma que nos conviene cuando
tenemos un punto y la pendiente es jay -
la segunda coordenada o sea x0 al
cuadrado es igual a la pendiente de la
recta normal es decir menos 1 entre 2
veces x 0 x voy a poner aquí x menos el
punto en la primera coordenada o sea x0
va esto de aquí es la ecuación de la
recta normal entonces vamos a ver lo que
nos importa es cuando x 0 es mayor que 0
verdad porque x 0 simplemente vive en el
primer cuadrante entonces solo nos
importan los valores del 0 a la derecha
entonces la ecuación de la recta normal
la podemos pues la podemos despejar un
poco más bonito verdad la podemos poner
como hoy en términos de x entonces si
sumamos x 0 al cuadrado de ambos lados
tenemos y es igual a déjame multiplicar
esto de por aquí obtenemos menos 1 entre
2 veces x 0 x x
y luego es menos por menos es más más
verdad menos menos es más 1 entre 2
porque los equis ceros se cancelan vale
luego tenemos que sumar este x 0 al
cuadrado de ambos lados hasta horita lo
único que he hecho es multiplicar esta
parte verdad es esta llave naranja pero
luego debo de sumar x 0 al cuadrado de
ambos lados entonces es más x 0 elevado
al cuadrado listo esto de aquí es la
ecuación en forma estándar es decir en
la cual ya está despejado
aquí tenemos m el valor de la pendiente
y esta de acá es la intersección en el
eje y que se llama b
ahora qué es lo que nos importa lo que
nos importa es donde esta expresión esta
recta intersecta a la parábola
nuevamente verdad la parábola tiene una
ecuación bien fácil simplemente es igual
a x al cuadrado entonces lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar las intersecciones de
modo que tenemos que igualar ambos
valores de g entonces los valores de x
para los cuales se intersectan son
aquellos valores en los cuales las que
son iguales de modo que necesitamos que
x al cuadrado sea igual a menos 1 entre
2 veces x 0 por x más un medio más x 0
al cuadrado
listo ok vamos a poner esto en la forma
general de una ecuación cuadrática para
intentar utilizar la fórmula
chicharronera entonces vamos a poner
todo a la izquierda e igualarlo a cero
tenemos x al cuadrado más 1 entre 2 x 0
x x menos
un medio más x0 al cuadrado igual a cero
va lo único que hice fue tomar toda esta
expresión y pasarla a la izquierda pero
esto de aquí ya es una ecuación
cuadrática estándar entonces ahora
podemos determinar cuáles son aquellos
valores de x que anulan esta expresión y
esto lo que nos diría es donde nuestra
recta normal y la parábola se
intersectan vale vamos a aplicar la
fórmula chicharronera aquí
entonces x es igual a tiene que ser
menos b b es igual a 1 entre 2 x 0
entonces le pongo menos 1 entre 2 x 0
luego es más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada o sea esta expresión al
cuadrado es 1 entre 4 x 0 al cuadrado
menos 4 hace entonces vamos aquí hay uno
que es esta expresión de aquí menos por
menos se vuelve más entonces simplemente
nos queda cuatro veces lo de la derecha
más cuatro veces esta expresión cuatro
veces esto es simplemente dos más cuatro
veces x 0 al cuadrado lo único que hice
fue poner 4 ha expresado pues ya de
forma simplificada verdad el menos por
menos se hace más y nos queda cuatro
veces simplemente es 2
y esté más nos quedó feo más x 0 elevado
al cuadrado va todo esto tenemos que
dividirlo entre 2a y como es uno es
entre 2 vamos a ver si podemos
simplificar esta expresión recuerda lo
que estamos haciendo simplemente estamos
encontrando donde la recta normal y la
parábola se intersectan va entonces que
obtenemos pues parece feo verdad pero
con un poco de suerte vamos a poder
simplificarlo entonces vamos a
factorizar vamos a factorizar me va a
aparecer un truco de pero con un poco de
práctica pues ya uno aprende a hacer
este tipo de cosas entonces vamos a
dividir todo entre dos primero nos queda
menos 1 entre 4 x 0 simplemente dividir
entre 2 el primer término verdad más
menos un medio d
y aquí tenemos que poner la raíz
cuadrada de déjame ver qué puedo hacer
con esto de aquí a ver si aquí en esta
expresión factor hizo un pues digamos un
4 entre x0 al cuadrado se ve súper
antinatural verdad pero ahorita vamos a
ver por qué funciona este término de
aquí
sería un x a la 0 elevado a la cuarta
más y ahora que le pasa al 2 el 2 se
vuelve un medio x x 0 al cuadrado solo
para verificarlo al multiplicar 4 por un
medio nos queda 2 y x0 al cuadrado entre
x 0 al cuadrado se vuelve uno de modo
que la multiplicación nos da 2 y luego
hay que sumar y pues si factor izamos
esta expresión simplemente nos queda un
dieciseisavo déjame moverme a la derecha
ok vamos a cerrar la raíz puedes
verificar que esto funciona si
multiplicas esta expresión vas a ver que
regresas a la primera entonces si
multiplicas y desarrollas término a
término pues a ver fíjate por aquí pues
obtenemos lo mismo verdad ahora con un
poco de suerte ya vamos a poder
factorizar entonces la intersección de
la recta normal y la parábola es igual a
menos 1 entre 4 x 0 + menos un medio
y la raíz cuadrada
de esta expresión tenemos cuatro entre
x0 al cuadrado y mira esta expresión de
aquí es un binomio al cuadrado jaime vas
a decir cómo le hice para ver eso
y luego luego ahorita no me voy a meter
en detalles pero fíjate es x0 al
cuadrado más un cuarto al cuadrado si no
me crees hace el binomio al cuadrado y
vas a ver que regresas a esta expresión
pero bueno ahí tenemos ya un cuadrado
entonces va a ser fácil sacar la raíz
cuadrada entonces obtenemos lo siguiente
los puntos en los cuales intersectan la
recta tangente y la parábola quien ya se
hizo un poco largo este problema pero es
menos 1 entre 4 x 0 más menos un medio
de la raíz cuadrada de esto la raíz del
primer término es 2 entre x 0 y la raíz
del segundo es x 0 elevado al cuadrado
más un cuarto
va esto de aquí es igual a vamos a
simplificar un poquito menos 1 entre 4 x
0 y luego nos queda más menos en un
medio con el 2 se cancelan va ahí
tenemos un 1 entonces es más menos 1
entre x 0 x x 0 al cuadrado entonces
obtenemos 1 entre x 0
no deja mejor ya ponerlo de una vez que
esté como x 0 entonces x 0 ahí están no
voy a poner mejor con otro color para
que veas que termino es entonces este
término nos queda x 0 y luego tenemos
uno más uno dividido entre 4 x 0 1 entre
4 x 0 va entonces estos de aquí son los
dos puntos en los cuales la recta normal
y la parábola intersectan déjame dejarlo
muy claro estos dos puntos son en el
dibujo este de aquí el x 0 verdad es
este punto y este punto de acá ahora
tenemos un + - entonces esta es la
versión más y esta es la versión menos
vamos a verificar que en efecto la
versión más se simplifica para hacer x0
esto es algo que debería de pasar si
todo tiene sentido en esta vida entonces
vamos a obtener la versión con más a ver
si realmente obtenemos x 0 entonces en
el primer cuadrante x es igual a menos 1
entre 4 x 0 más x 0 + 1 entre 4 x 0 y
esto tiene todo el sentido del mundo
fíjate este menos con este más
cancela simplemente nos queda x 0 y x0
es uno de los puntos de intersección lo
cual tiene todo el sentido del mundo
así fue como empezamos a definir el
problema esto de aquí es en el primer
cuadrante va entonces ahora sí vamos a
la intersección en el segundo cuadrante
eso va a ser para cuando tomemos -
entonces nos queda x del segundo
cuadrante es igual a menos 1 entre 4 x 0
- qué tal estamos en la versión de menos
menos esta expresión menos x 0 -1 entre
4 x 0 no entre 4 x 0 sale ahora que
tenemos vamos a tener estas dos cosas
restadas podemos simplificar los nos
queda menos x 0 y cuando juntamos dos
menos uno cuartos nos queda un menos un
medio entonces es menos 1 entre 2 x 0
vale ok entonces la coordenada en x de
la intersección en el segundo cuadrante
de la recta por x0 está dada por esta
expresión voy a desplazarme un poco pues
no quiero que se me acabe el espacio
entonces x2 o sea la coordenada en x de
la segunda intersección de la recta
normal es igual a menos x 0 - 1 entre 2
veces x 0 muy bien vamos súper súper
bien esto por sí mismo es un resultado
padrísimo desafortunadamente todavía no
hemos terminado con el problema lo
siguiente que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar aquel punto x0 que nos genere
el punto extremo de intersección o bien
que nos genere la recta extrema pues
entonces esencialmente lo que queremos
es encontrar
x 0 nos da el valor de x de intersección
más grande como le hacemos para
determinar ese punto de intersección
máximo a pues ya tenemos la intersección
en el segundo cuadrante y está en
función de la coordenada en x del punto
de intersección en el primer cuadrante
puesto como función nos queda igual a
menos x 0 - 1 entre 2 x 0 esto va a
alcanzar un punto crítico ya sea mínimo
o máximo cuando su derivada sea igual a
0 ojo aquí las notaciones bien poco
convencionales usualmente tenemos jesse
x es ahorita lo que voy a hacer es
derivar x2 con respecto a x 0 entonces x
prima nx zero es igual a aquí tenemos
que derivar verdad es menos 1 y luego
hay que restar 1 / 2 x este es lo mismo
que x 0 a la menos 1 entonces nos queda
menos 1 por x 0 al menos dos simplemente
derivamos verdad
entonces esto es x 0 a la menos 1
una vez más el exponente baja y el
exponente disminuye en un ok entonces
esto de aquí es la derivada del segundo
punto de intersección con respecto al
primer punto de intersección voy a
escribirlo por aquí abajo x2 evaluado en
el primer punto de intersección y eso
derivado con respecto a x0 o sea con
respecto a la intersección en el primer
cuadrante es igual a menos 1 y luego
menos x menos da más entonces nos queda
más un medio de bueno algo poner aquí x
0 al cuadrado
ahora x 2 va a alcanzar un máximo un
mínimo donde esto es igual a cero vale
entonces vamos a resolver esta ecuación
de aquí para encontrar cuál x0 nos va a
ayudar a resolver el problema entonces
sumando 1 tenemos 1 entre 2 x 0 al
cuadrado es igual a 1
de modo que
2x 0 al cuadrado es igual a uno
simplemente invertimos ambos lados de la
ecuación o bien podemos poner que x 0 al
cuadrado es igual a un medio dividiendo
entre 2 ambos lados de la ecuación y
finalmente sacando raíz cuadrada
obtenemos que x es igual a 1 / raíz de 2
tomamos la versión positiva de la raíz
porque x 0 siempre es positivo bueno ya
estamos a punto de acabar ya encontramos
el valor de x0 que nos da nuestra recta
normal extrema verdad déjame pintarlo
con este color
este valor de x0 ya sabemos que es x0 es
igual a 1 entre raíz de 2 bueno ahora lo
que queremos es encontrar la ecuación de
la recta normal extrema y para encontrar
esto ya nada más regresamos aquí a la
izquierda a la ecuación general aquí a
esto que estoy metiendo en un rectángulo
y si queremos encontrar la recta normal
que pasa por este punto extremo verdad
este que ya encontramos que es 1 / raíz
de 2 simplemente hay que sustituir este
valor en la ecuación general que ya
encontramos
ahora sí ya estamos a punto de llegar a
este aquí fue un problema está verdad
pero tenemos menos x0 al cuadrado x 0 al
cuadrado es un medio de nuestras raíces
2 al cuadrado es un medio eso de ahí es
igual a menos 1 entre 2 veces x 0 vale
entonces vamos a ser cuidadosos aquí
tenemos un medio por 1 entre 1 entre
raíz de 2 que es igual a raíz de 2 va
todo eso x x menos x 0 x 0 es uno entre
raíz de 2 vale excelente vamos a
simplificar esto un poquito para ya
obtener nuestra respuesta final de modo
que la ecuación de la recta normal nos
queda ya menos un medio es igual a a ver
si aquí multiplicamos esto nos queda
menos raíz de 2 entre 2 x verdad y luego
si multiplicamos estos dos términos por
el segundo sumando de este paréntesis
tenemos a ver - con menos es más
y nos queda un medio porque las raíces
de 2 se cancelan listo
ahora estoy aquí sí verdad ok entonces
ya para terminar simplemente sumamos un
medio de ambos lados de la ecuación que
obtenemos pues obtenemos que la ecuación
de la recta normal extrema es igual a
menos raíz de 2 entre 2 x y cuando
sumamos un medio de ambos lados
obtenemos que queda más 1 listo
uff esta de aquí es la ecuación de la
recta normal extrema claro asumiendo que
no metí la pata en las cuentas pero
aunque esto haya pasado ahora tenemos
una mucho mejor idea de cómo resolver
este problema larguísimo